Heath Ledger who oh my God you know what
a performance what a pleasure to have
gotten to work with him and just to see
him you know and how much he put himself
into the Joker and I would and I was
watching it going yeah this is
absolutely fantastic are we in trouble
here of when Chris and I first sat down
we said you're not the problem what
Batman is is that the villains are
always more interesting right and so
Batman actually he's very close to being
a villain himself so let's never let him
become dull by comparison and
unfortunately I was sitting there going
I'm feeling a little bit dull by
comparison because he is just like
killing this and but I'm so proud of
that film I love it The Dark Knight is
absolutely extraordinary you know and it
was such a pleasure to have gone away
with ease I don't want to kill you